[Aplausos]
les pasó cuando eran chicos que alguien
que conocían se murió
un familiar el familiar de un amigo
alguien en el barrio alguien de la
escuela
es probable que muchos los que estemos
acá ahora tengamos en nuestro recuerdo
alguna muerte que hayamos tenido que
atravesar en la infancia
quizás si hacemos memoria podamos hasta
recordar la manera en como nos
acompañaron en ese momento
algo podría haber sido mejor de ese
acompañamiento
hoy podríamos hacer algo distintos como
adultos para acompañar a ese niño o esa
niña que fuimos
hoy quiero hablar de dos cosas quiero
hablar de niños y de muertes niños y
muerte dicho así parecen como dos
palabras que ni se deberían tocar como
si fueran dos mundos separados
tal vez ya les pasó y si no no sería
nada raro que les pase que venga un niño
que puede ser su hijo
su sobrino su nieto si son docentes
puede ser su alumno y les diga que puede
ser una pregunta
mi mamá está enferma
mi mamá está flaquita los médicos nos
dijeron que está grave
mi mamá se va a morir
se pusieron a pensar porque en general
los adultos hablamos poco el tema de la
muerte con los chicos niños y muertes
que dirían ustedes la muerte
es un tema de la infancia
me encantaría me encantaría escuchar sus
respuestas
me voy a tomar el atrevimiento de
contestar yo definitivamente la muerte
es un tema de la infancia
porque entre otras cosas los niños son
curiosos vieron y la muerte
es un misterio
los chicos a la muerte la ven a diario
en la naturaleza la escuchan en los
cuentos que les contamos a la noche y a
veces la tienen que vivir cuando pierden
a un ser querido a un ser cercano
y esto sucede mucho más allá de que a
nosotros como adultos el tema de la
muerte nos guste no nos guste o nos
genere rechazo
los chicos a la muerte la juegan por
ejemplo con una espada de madera jugamos
a que te mataba
la piensan mamá
una pregunta ahora que el gatito se
murió
a mi vida
y a veces con insistencia los buscan te
hice una pregunta
mamá se va a morir
pero claro a veces cuando quieren
incluso a veces cuando necesitan hablar
de este tema se encuentran con un gran
obstáculo
los adultos
como le voy a hablar de muerte lo voy a
trauma el chiquito encima que se murió
su abuelo yo le voy a sacar el tema es
muy chiquito todavía no entiendes
soy pediatra vengo del mundo de los
cuidados paliativos para quienes no
estén del todo familiarizados les cuento
que en cuidados paliativos nuestra tarea
consiste en acompañar e intentar aliviar
el sufrimiento de personas de cualquier
edad que atraviesan una enfermedad grave
crónica avanzada nosotros decimos una
enfermedad mena zante para la vida
acompañamos a estas personas ya sus
familias trabajo como decían en el
equipo de cuidados paliativos del
hospital zonal de bariloche y trabajo
además en una ong donde nuestro
propósito es hacer que los cuidados
paliativos sean un poco más conocidos
nosotros sabemos que los cuidados
paliativos son un derecho pero es
difícil reclamar derechos que uno no
conoce
uno de los proyectos que estamos
llevando adelante ya hace algunos años
se llama duelo en escuelas el objetivo
que nos propusimos fue acercar el tema
del duelo el tema de la muerte de
ámbitos educativos porque confiamos que
la escuela es un lugar donde estos temas
se puedan reflexionar se pueden aprender
y se pueden enseñar este proyecto nos
permitió un montón de cosas además de
conocer un montón de escuelas conocimos
un montón de alumnos y de docentes
conocimos un montón de gente conocimos
muchos puntos de vista en relación a la
muerte
una cosa que escuchamos con frecuencia
es que nos dicen particularmente
docentes y a veces docentes con muchos
años de trayectoria yo con el tema de la
muerte no sé bien qué hacer en esos
educadores y los que venimos del campo
de la salud un poco nos parecemos no nos
hablaron mucho de este tema
hay una situación que nosotros vemos en
las escuelas que nuestro equipo de
trabajo le pusimos un nombre de fantasía
lo llamamos la paradoja de la medianera
un gran nombre parece una cosa muy
sencilla imaginen una pared acá y de
este lado de la pared está cuarto grado
la maestra o el maestro de 4º grado no
sabemos bien por qué pero le gusta el
tema de la muerte entonces lo provoca
con sus alumnos trae un cuento una
película saca el tema
de este lado la pared está quinto grado
la maestra o el maestro de quinto no
sabemos bien por qué quizás porque tuvo
una experiencia traumática cuando era
chico
quizás porque le parece que la muerte no
hay que hablar en la escuela no importa
por qué pero en quinto grado no se habla
de la muerte de que depende les pregunto
que los chicos de esta escuela puedan
hablar el tema de la muerte
depende de qué grado van
para decirlo más fácil depende del azar
no debemos dejar un tema tan importante
librado al azar
este tema se puede aprender se puede
enseñar las escuelas pueden ser un lugar
le enseñaron alguna vez a un chico o una
chica a andar en bicicleta pero sin
rueditas
supongo que sí cómo fue la experiencia
se subieron a la bicicleta pedalearon no
porque enseñar a un chico andar en
bicicleta sin rueditas es una
experiencia distinta es dejar que
pedalean ir atrás a lo sumo al costado y
evitar que se golpeen bueno hablar de la
muerte con los chicos a veces soy parece
a eso les voy a contar una pequeña
historia
hace dos años aproximadamente
acompañamos a una mujer de unos 60 años
del hospital y acompañamos un montón de
meses la última etapa en su casa
tenía una enfermedad grave tenía un
cáncer muy avanzado un día nos llama una
de sus hijas y nos dice que su mamá
había muerto fuimos hasta la casa
llegamos un montón de gente familiares y
nos saludamos saludamos especialmente a
los hijos con quienes veníamos
trabajando hace muchos meses y les
preguntamos si podríamos hacer algo por
ellos y una de sus hijas nos dijo que sí
nos preguntó si podríamos hablar con su
pequeña hija de cuatro años claro
fuimos la buscamos caminamos por el
hermoso jardín de esa casa nos sentamos
abajo un árbol
cuatro años y le preguntamos cómo estaba
cómo estás no nos dijo nada
entonces preguntamos qué hace toda esta
gente reunida acá y ahí empezó a hablar
nos dijo que su abuela se había muerto y
nos preguntó si sabíamos que era la
muerte
no nos dejó ni contestar y nos explicó
que la muerte es irse de viaje saltando
de nube en nube
y como más arriba de las nubes están las
estrellas de estrella en la estrella
hasta encontrar la estrella más linda
vieron cómo es la poética que puede
tener un chico de los cuatro años no no
le interesó a esta nena mucho su poética
porque siguió hablando y nos contó que
el último tiempo su abuela estaba muy
triste y que se había muerto de tristeza
como quien dice en ese instante paramos
la oreja siguió hablando siguió hablando
y nos contó que su mamá está muy triste
estamos llorando
o sea reflexionó si mi abuela se había
muerto de tristeza mi mamá que estaba
triste se iba a morir de tristeza ese
fue el primer momento en el que como
quien dice abrimos la boca no
enfáticamente no tu mamá no se va a
morir de tristeza tu mama está triste
esa tristeza de a poquito se va a ir
lavando se va a ir yendo se va a ir
transformando en otra cosa que fue
hablar de la muerte con esta nena
fue evitar que se golpee y golpearse a
veces es unir cosas que no tienen que
estar unidas
como hablar de la muerte con los chicos
en lo posible
sin miedos y si tienen miedo atravesando
el miedo vieron que los chicos les
decimos tenéis que ser valiente
bueno creo ser valiente no es no tener
miedo ser valiente saber qué hacer con
ese miedo y también si pueden sí podemos
pensando de tanto en tanto en la muerte
es un poco más difícil todavía encarar
estas charlas a veces si no sabemos ni
siquiera que pensamos nosotros los
adultos del tema si la última vez que
pensamos en la muerte fue hace muchos
años
cuando fue la última vez que pensaron en
la muerte
no hay una fórmula para hablar con los
chicos de la muerte pero si hay algunas
formas a veces hay que poner a los
chicos a hablar
es más difícil todavía encarar estas
conversaciones y no sabemos ni siquiera
qué piensan ellos del tema el otro día
en el hospital tenía una conversación
con un señor de 40 años bueno yo casi
tengo 40 con un muchacho de 40 años
que me contaba que su padre tenía una
enfermedad tenía un cáncer avanzado y yo
le pregunté por su hijo que tenía 7 le
digo están pudiendo hablar con él le
contaron lo que tiene el abuelo claro
por supuesto desde el principio que
tiene cáncer que es grave y en esta
última semana yo hablé con él de que se
puede morir le dije yo él siguió
hablando y en un momento hizo un
silencio vieron cuando estamos hablando
y se nos viene una idea que nos paraliza
y él dice ah
pero el que habla siempre soy yo
eso nunca escucho lo que él tiene para
decir
yo como quien dice le bajo línea
pongamos a hablar a los chicos de la
muerte no se van a trauma
y quien les dice les regalen una gran
imagen poética
tampoco sucede eso que a veces se
escucha que por hablar de la muerte
en estos años aprendí muchas cosas
porque tuve oportunidad hablar con un
montón de chicos del tema de la muerte a
veces los chicos eran los mismos que
estaban enfermos a veces eran hermanos
de hijos de nietos de
y aprendí algunas cosas aprendí que para
hablar de la muerte no siempre es
necesario usar palabras también se puede
usar cuentos canciones símbolos dibujos
a veces se pueden usar silencios somos
los adultos los que creemos que cuando
decimos hablar siempre hay que usar las
palabras
también aprendí que cada uno tiene su
estilo que no hay un único estilo
ustedes tienen su estilo
pero aprendí algo que no puedo sacar de
la cabeza para hablar del tema de la
muerte y otros temas tan importantes con
los chicos no hay que olvidarse de dos
características dos rasgos dos
cualidades hay que ser claros
y hay que ser sinceros que puede ser una
pregunta si mi mamá se va a morir
a veces depende el momento depende del
niño que está delante depende de la
situación la respuesta tiene que ser si
no digo que sea una respuesta fácil pero
mamá se va a morir no sabemos cuando
está muy enferma vamos a hacer todo lo
posible para que no sufra a veces la
respuesta puede ser devolver la pregunta
vieron que los chicos a veces cuando
quieren hablar de algo importante lo
dicen en forma de pregunta
qué estabas pensando porque se te
ocurrió preguntar eso vos que imaginas
ustedes quizás se les estén ocurriendo
otras respuestas mejores en este momento
pero lo cierto es que con más frecuencia
de lo que nos gustaría las respuestas
que escuchamos son otras cómo se te
ocurre preguntar eso no no no no mamá va
a estar bien vamos a estar bien no
pienses mejor en eso
esas respuestas no son claras y sinceras
saben lo que es ser sincero no ser
sincero es no mentir
tampoco con todo esto de los niños y la
muerte estoy diciendo que cuando
terminemos estas charlas salgamos de
este salón busquemos a los niños de
nuestra familia
los sentemos en ronda tomemos la palabra
y digamos niños hoy vamos a hablar de
algo muy importante no no no no eso
sería una gran exageración solo estoy
diciendo
que tengamos un poquito más presente el
tema finalmente
más allá de que más allá de que cada uno
de ustedes piense algo crea algo o
sienta algo en relación a este tema es
una responsabilidad que tenemos los
adultos de estar ahí listos disponibles
para cuando un chico quiera o necesite
hablar de este tema el tema de la muerte
no es un tema que tengamos que dejar
librado al azar
la forma como los chicos
afrontan una perdida los va modelando
los va transformando en los adultos que
van a hacer nosotros somos lo que somos
en parte por cómo afrontamos las
pérdidas
puede ser que para algunos el tema de la
muerte sea un poco más fácil para
algunos un poco más difícil pero hay
algo que no deberíamos olvidar dejará
fuera de la conversación el tema de la
muerte es dejar afuera un pedazo de vida
es dejar afuera un tema de vital
importancia gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]